merci
membre de l'équipage
sait
oh mon Dieu
oh wow
c'est
étranger étranger
il ne pleut pas qu'est-ce que
tu as là oh c'est une
[ __ ] de vélo un siège de vélo ouais ils me poursuivent
la pluie et les vélos ouais la pluie
ouais l'a apporté  tout le chemin d'
Amsterdam
ENT
euh
je ne sais pas s'il va se détacher
il est trop croustillant
un vrai s'ouvrirait
c'est tout ce que je peux obtenir
ouais
oh regarde ça oh tout un tas de clés
là-bas
sympa
quel gros glissement e6l
[Rires]
euh
plein de ces déchets Happy Gas
ouais ouais
sympa un frère si triste
des photos ici ouais tu l'as juste
ici d'accord
je vais traîner mon grappin oh ouais tu
as raison c'est si lourd ouais
vois si je peux le
comprendre  ici d'accord je pense que j'ai compris
oh ouais
ça vient
regarde les bulles là oh mon Dieu
ça sort maintenant qu'est-ce que
j'ai c'est une moto oh
ouais le cadre oh mon Dieu je t'ai dit que
c'était plus lourd je viens d'avoir un cadre de moto
oh  mon Dieu l'a eu avec le grappin
on
dirait
qu'il y a une veste là aussi
du
béton ouais on peut on peut l'avoir je
ne sais pas comment je l'ai eu
ouais on pourrait en avoir besoin ouais trois
aimants oui c'est
ça continuer parlait
des beaux avec le nom de la
ville d'accord ouais
étranger
d'accord lentement lentement
[Musique]
allez
ouais
c'est les nouvelles de la ville
oh ouais oh des bulles oui et des bulles d'accord
intéressant d'accord
vraiment lourd mais il y a des bulles là-bas
donc ça veut dire que ça arrive c'est
bon ça arrive
c'est peut-être la plus grosse trouvaille du
jour ouais oh  mon Dieu
c'est en forme de moto
on a besoin de plus de monde ouais comment
tu veux aider en
français c'est bien
j'ai une paire de gants de rechange
oh non non ils sont partis
ok
mec
ok c'était quoi d'accord d'accord
c'est bon ça
bouge facilement quand tu es juste
là ouais parfait peut-être juste
là d'accord d'accord oui d'accord oh d'accord d'accord
tenons-le ici posez-le debout
dessus ouais posez-le debout dessus
qu'est-ce qu'on a un
aimant là-bas aussi
regardez tout le pétrole que nous allons
sortir, donc
nous avons un autre gars là-bas,
il a l'air assez fort aussi et vous
avez compris
ouais nous
il vient à contrecœur
est-ce que nous passons une bonne journée les gars ouais
ouais mettez l'aimant là-bas aussi
d'accord  juste pour le tenir
ici nous en avons deux ouais nous en avons deux maintenant
maintenant un autre
désolé non désolé douche d'accord d'accord c'est
trois d'accord d'
accord
peut-être cette personne de plus d'accord pour faire
tourner certaines personnes un deux trois oh mon
Dieu d'accord regarde ça ce n'est pas  une petite
moto un
go mec je suis debout
oh ouais toi toi je suis debout dessus donc
je ne peux pas bouger d'
accord d'accord c'est bon
d'accord nous recevons une salve d'applaudissements
merci nous ne l'avons pas sorti  encore
[Musique]
Je vais essayer celui-ci
étranger
ouais
oh mon Dieu ouais
les filles sont là oui monsieur génial ce
mec il
arrive oh il a un enfant ah et une
glace ok ok
il y a plus de gens qui viennent
[Rires]
c'est le principal  cours d'accord on est prêt d'accord allez on
fait une pause pas
besoin de battre un record
regarde la foule là-bas c'est fou
merci étranger
sur un deux trois d'accord
mets la corde vers le bas
pêche à l'aimant en France
d'accord
sur cette route
euh
[  Applaudissements]
ah wow
[Applaudissements]
oh mon dieu bravo oh ouais
[Musique]
Je savais surtout ouais
mais pas trop ouais ouais d'accord ouais [
Musique]
ok parfait Nikki je vais bien on
vient tous de ce côté
um
étranger
tout le monde d'
accord  ok c'est
bon juste pour filmer leur dos alors
ouais c'est bon ouais non non non non non non
non
étranger [
Rires]
c'est mort
non tu peux le restaurer ouais
ok on en a trouvé un en Angleterre et un gars
l'a ramené chez lui pour le restaurer ouais
j'ai vu  l'après-midi
mais tu peux tu peux le revendre à la
ferraille aussi ouais d'accord ouais la ferraille
c'est trop de travail je pense que c'est euh mais
celui-là est tellement assez fort pour apprendre
celui-là est tellement lourd ouais étranger